the jurogan experience and one of the
things that i wanted to talk to because
i haven't talked to you since the
pandemic star last time i talked to you
was screwball right
like how long ago was that oh yeah what
2019. yeah i was 20 right before the
[ __ ] hit the fan that was the last time
we talked we were talking about that
documentary and then when all this
happened and so much of the wackiness
and you know the controversy is coming
out of florida like you embrace the
chaos of florida yeah florida [ __ ] is
our genre and it's our also our top
export i think is as well it's really
what we provide the rest of but for you
you i mean look about how much your work
is about florida
the coking cowboys series you know all
the stuff on a-rod like all the there's
there's so much of your
your work
the petrifying i'm a florida native you
know in a lifelong miami and i think the
petrifying thing that i've learned
through the years and it's not my theory
uh td allman called miami the city of
the future and effectively
the florida of today is the america of
tomorrow and
more importantly the miami of today more
specifically the miami of today is the
america of tomorrow so if you want to
know
what
challenges will face or calamities will
befall us as a nation in the years or
even decades to come and you need only
look at the canary in the coal mine
which is which is south florida do you
think that's because of it's very
vulnerable to climate change first of
all right like there's there's
estimates about how long miami can last
yeah not good yeah they don't
they think we got about two decades
right isn't that the the current thought
i'm a renter let me put you that way
i've lived there my whole life i don't
own any property in miami it's probably
a good move i'm not bullish it does it
seems like it's going to go underwater
right yeah it'll definitely be
underwater it's just a question of when
it's just a question all like there like
the ground itself is very porous is that
correct yeah i mean you know we had uh
uh reclaimed wetlands
that's miami beach that's where
champlain towers is reclaimed wetlands
what does that mean it was [ __ ]
mangroves swamps yes swamp and that we
reclaimed which means we filled it in
and there's still porous limestone
underneath that champlain towers only
had water coming at it from the front
the back above and below but other than
that it was totally dry this is the
tower that collapsed collapsed yeah i
mean just battered we're getting
battered they were on that porous
limestone yeah that was oh yeah yeah
built on reclaimed wetlands and so i'll
tell you right now as we speak this is
the
um the king tides you know what the king
tides are no they happen every september
october and november not the entire time
but there's like a week here a weekend
there for those three months
it is what we call sunny day flooding
so it has to do with the tides it has to
do with the
the distance between the sun and the
moon and the earth and
it floods in the sunlight it we can get
as much as 12 inches
12 inches above
the
highest high tide of the year so it's
just it's not from rain it's now here's
the problem we're still in hurricane
season which means rain exacerbates it
inclement weather can we're totally
[ __ ] when it rains on top of the king
ties but this is just like
a day like you just
if you were in a low-lying area or
waterfront or oceanfront bay front
that's just what sunny day it's
perfectly it could be perfectly
beautiful and you could have as much as
12 inches
above the highest high tide so it's just
an unusual level of the ocean yeah it's
just a quirk of of the tides it happens
every year uh off and on for three
months
yeah that's in in the day we call it
sunny day flooding that's the thing
that we have there i mean you know miami
we make it rain but we now we have sunny
sunny day flooding is a thing and
there's nothing they can do like new
orleans like put up some sort of a
some sort of a wall
damn so the the army corps of engineers
proposed a kind of futuristic
post-apocalyptic you know after the
flood well pre-flood kind of a wall and
miami said no gracias no thank you we
don't want that we'll we'll we'll fend
for ourselves did they say no because it
was too expensive or did they say no
because no the army corps of engineers i
think was good i think it was gonna be
federally funded they just didn't want
this unsightly unseemly kind of a wall
in our beautiful
town but what they did one is they
wanted a signature bridge we're building
like this 800 million dollar bridge that
we don't need that's but it's it's super
it's super pretty as we say in miami
it's super pretty and somebody probably
got a good deal oh yeah you better
believe the contractors that's the thing
that's why the miami of today is the
america of tomorrow it's really the
corruption dysfunction and non-stop
construction that's really what it is
it's this anything goes wild west kind
of mentality because you know i said
this before on the show you know la is
where you go when you want to be
somebody new york is where you go when
you are somebody and miami is where you
go and you want to be somebody else it's
always been a sunny place for shady
people the florida man phenomenon it's
just like you know it just
if you have
it's not new england it's not what's
your name who's your daddy everyone's
nouveau riche in miami so no one cares
where your money came from as long as
the booze is flowing and everybody's
dancing the music's going nobody gives a
[ __ ] and it's always been that place
it's always been that party place you
were you were telling me before about
how during uh
was it the 70s the 80s these recording
artists would go down to miami yeah but
listen uh miami is just it's america's
casablanca you know and so some of the
biggest records of all time
um i mean back when that was a business
like you could sell
tens of millions of albums
uh everybody went to miami eric clapton
was one of the first jimmy buffett the
bee gees
the eagles crosby stills nash and young
um the allman brothers fleetwood mac and
they were doing all those records that
we all still know today from the 70s
they recorded uh mixed or mastered at
least in part um uh uh glen fry and don
henley wrote the lyrics to hotel
california in a rented mansion on miami
beach uh where it had that had been the
love nest um of howard hughes and ava
gardner uh uh winston churchill used it
as a winter home uh and um the watergate
burglars and howard hunt used it as well
and then um steven stills used it he was
hanging out there with like shel
silverstein they were it was like a
weird scene and then uh eventually the
eagles came down to do hotel california
and wrote the lyrics they locked
themselves these two guys in a [ __ ]
room and they they just the housekeeper
left sandwiches and
and drinks at the door because the door
was closed and they came down in bath
robes one day with with legal pads
yellow legal pads and
said we have it we have we have we have
the lyrics and so everybody everybody
and it was a communal scene too it's
kind of like your place with the you
know everybody just sort of like stops
crying
people stop by to get it it was like
that because you had all these artists
in every room like so there was pick up
basketball games outside you'd drive up
and there'd be the bee gees playing the
allman brothers playing eric clapton in
a pickup basketball game and they to
this day
criteria studios they have a wooden
upright piano and the rumor has it one
day there was an artist i won't mention
the name was playing and had a baggie of
cocaine on the top of the piano and he
was playing and the baggy fell
open
fell boom puff of smoke on the keys of
the piano appropriately and he grabbed
the bag and salvaged what he could and
then for the next several months the
people at the studio who worked would
stick a straw between the keys on the on
the piano and try to mostly dust they
were probably snorting but like we're
just trying to salvage whatever they
could from there so the the the joke was
that um
they had uh a line item on the uh the
bills because that's the thing they were
away from the watchful eyes and ears of
the labels which were all based in new
york and la so they would go to miami
and no one knew what the [ __ ] was going
i didn't have publicists or producers
from or executives rather from from the
recording studios so they would send
them bills to pay for the studio time
there'd be a line item for cocaine but
you couldn't say cocaine um and i think
by the way cocaine was at that time was
probably part of the appeal of bringing
the artist to miami to be fair probably
right but it was under the the category
of piano tuning
was was the cocaine so you get like some
you know someone at you know accounts
and at a record label call up and say
hey i have a question about this this
invoice um it's it's there's five
thousand dollars here for piano tuning
but there's only one ballot on the album
so what's with all this [ __ ] piano
tuning you have there's there was an act
uh i'm not going to say it but there was
a band
who came down in the 80s to record a
criteria
and then they came down again in the 90s
and the guy who runs the studio trevor
his mom was the manager before him so he
was a little kid running around this
scene if you can imagine a little kid in
miami in the 70s running around this
scene this is an incredible place aretha
franklin did the respect record at
criteria james brown did i feel good
recorded that song at criteria it's a
really historic place and so he this
band comes in and he says the lead
singer he says hey listen i don't know
if you remember you know you were down
here 15 years ago whatever back in the
late 70s early 80s doing this this
record
and the singer says
i have no memory of that
whatsoever except for one thing
he said one night apparently
we were done recording here and someone
took us into the neighborhood it's like
in a residential kind of area into the
neighborhood to this woman's house
and she brought out a brick of cocaine
an entire kilo of cocaine he said i'd
never seen that before she put it down
on the coffee table we're sitting on the
couch she put it down like there's a big
band uh they put it she put it down on
the coffee table she cut it open
and all i remember from my entire
experience in miami is the smell of that
entire kilo of cocaine like just what it
feels like when an entire like an entire
kilo of cocaine is opened up
before you and it hits and it hits you
have you ever done coke never me neither
never but hearing that
i want a sniff
i just want to know take away from that
i want to know what that's like
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify